this is so aggressively unfun it's
almost
impressive so a few months ago i
embarked on a mission
that i knew from the beginning would be
would be difficult but has proven far
more challenging than i ever
anticipated it's the sort of mission
that tries your souls shows you who you
are what you're made of test your medal
the mission is to laugh at a joke told
by a feminist comedian
are you serious now to be clear here
just to be just to be just
so he can get all the technicalities
clear the goal is
is is not to laugh at a feminist
comedian because we can all do that
that's very easy to do you can easily
laugh at them
the goal is to laugh with them to laugh
at their material
to laugh when it seems like they want
you to laugh
and in the way they want you to laugh so
uh so far i've tried to laugh at jokes
from samantha b
and hannah gadsby if you watch those
videos you know that i i tried my
hardest i did
i dedicated myself to the task and just
came up empty i found myself
not only not laughing but in fact nearly
weeping
as i as i stared into the bleak abyss
where laughter and joy and humor dies it
was a it was a deeply chilling and
unsettling experience but now we're
going to try it again
i'm going to give this one more try this
time with chelsea handler
now chelsea handler is an interesting
case because she reminds me a little bit
of like your eccentric childless aunt
who always smells
vaguely of cat litter and chardonnay i'm
a little burnt out
so sometimes don't shoot me i have a
glass of wine with buster here
and she has a boyfriend with a ponytail
who she invites to thanksgiving
and he tells you about his weird hobby
like collecting gerbils or something
this analogy is maybe getting a little
bit too specific i don't know
the point is chelsea handler is weird
and sort of sad
but not often funny at least that's how
she comes across and you know i say this
admittedly as someone
who watched chelsea handler one time for
four minutes
15 years ago when she was on the what
was it the entertainment channel
and i had her on tv because i was
looking under the couch for the remote
so i could change it
and in that time that's like the only
time i've ever really been exposed to
her comedy
so um i made a lot of judgments based on
that experience
maybe they were unfair judgments and so
now we're going to give this a try let's
let's try to laugh let's go and we'll
start here with i think this is one of
her
more recent routines and let's just uh
let's see if we can get a chuckle out of
this and then he wanted to know about my
family history i was like that's not
what this is about nothing to see there
i was like my brother died when i was a
little girl my mom died like eight or
ten years ago
my dad's a huge pain in the ass so
hopefully he'll wrap things up this year
[Laughter]
and i said and quite frankly like i'm
ready to wrap it up too
i said dan i'm not suicidal you don't
have to worry about it but people say
life is too short i think it's too long
like there's so many annoying people out
here and i just can't deal with it i
said i'm losing my patience
okay so this isn't comedy so much as
it's a suicide note
uh there's there's literally no joke
here she's just talking about how much
she hates her family
and her own life and wants to die and
the cackling audience is laughing
yeah life is horrible i'm in despair
good one horrible life this is great
stuff
like i hope the people in the audience
never volunteer at a suicide hotline
that's all that's all i'm saying it's
just it's a very troubling reaction
but let's uh maybe it gets funnier let's
keep going i need you to help me with my
lack of patience
and he said okay give me some examples
of your lack of patience and i said okay
fine i was at a table like this
probably a little bigger with three of
my girlfriends before my session that
day with dan
my girlfriend orders a turkey burger no
onion
no bun no cheese that's fine we live in
l.a
so the server comes over with his hands
full with four plates
and comes over and we're all sitting at
him we're not even talking
and he says turkey burger who ordered
the turkey burger no onion
no bun no cheese and my friend is just
sitting there like stevie wonder playing
the piano
and he says it again louder turkey
burger no onion no bun
no cheese and this is her
i go hey
you can't order that and then i forgot
they ordered that
and i thought my jokes were bad all
right so again
i'm not sure where the joke is supposed
to be located here and i'll let that
play for a little while because i was
just i was sort of waiting
um for the joke there isn't this isn't
even try to laugh anymore this is find
the joke
it's like where's waldo the challenge is
just to figure out where the joke is
i mean forget about actually laughing i
don't even know where i'm supposed to
laugh
the audience on the other hand they just
laugh at everything i mean this woman
busts out
a stevie wonder joke in the year 2020
and the audience acts like it's the
funniest thing i've ever heard maybe
next you can make a joke about
telemarketers something really topical
hey what's the deal with telemarketers
huh you ever heard of these people
telemarketers
so annoying the audience would love that
that would that would kill this audience
and then of course at the end of the bit
um the punch line i guess
is that chelsea handler is a horrible
person which i've
been perfectly willing to believe she's
screaming at her friend in a restaurant
so what we've learned is that handler is
depressed
miserable suicidal and on top of it a
terrible friend
these are all excellent things to say
to your therapist it's just not fit for
a comedy stage
that's my only point but we'll uh we'll
keep going i said so that's one example
would you like to hear another he said
yes please go on
i said airports airports i can't deal
with the people that work at hudson
booksellers what's wrong with those
people
what's up with the slowness of the
transaction i can't deal with the
slowness of the transaction when i want
to buy a book are those people what is
wrong with are they koala bears
okay i i i don't i don't mean to keep
focusing on the audience but
it's the only interesting thing
happening in this clip and there's one
guy i don't know if you heard the one
guy
in particular in the audience and he
just lost it
on the koala bear joke koala bears
which didn't make sense anyway by the
way because actually koala bears can run
up to 30 miles
per hour and i did look that up so
they're not known for being slow
necessarily
but also what's the it just she says
koala bear
koala bear koala bear
koala bear that's rich is she performing
at a lunatic asylum
is it just me or is it getting crazier
out there
that would maybe make sense of the whole
thing and it would explain the white
jumpsuit she's wearing as well so
maybe that's it well um okay let's we'll
play this maybe to the end here
he said well how do you handle that i go
have to shoplift
[Laughter]
i said i get the book and i wave it to
the security camera
always i said i always say hey it's me
chelsea handler
i'm taking this because your koala bear
is on a branch somewhere in the back
i'm like i'm going to leave 40 bucks
here and hopefully
they'll find it when she comes out from
her nap if she'll find it before a
stranger does but it's on this bookshelf
i didn't steal i'm leaving and then i
skiddaddle
and dan was looking at me when i said
that i was like what is that white
privilege too
he's like no chelsea white people aren't
even doing that
okay that i'm just gonna cut that off
here uh
i don't even want to hear where that's
going because it's not going anywhere
none of this is going out
this is really just a woman complaining
about things this is just her
complaining
which there's no shortage of that in the
world already she basically took the
content
of any random marco polo that she sent
to one of her
middle-aged female friends and decided
to run with it as a comedy bit
which fine okay but but really if you're
gonna do that you should inject a couple
of
jokes here and there that's my i'm not a
stand-up comedian
you know don't take it for me but i feel
like if i was gonna do a comedy bit
i would want to have really probably a
lot of jokes right you probably want
at least a couple but but even really a
lot of jokes
everything you say should be a joke or
should be leading to a joke
i definitely wouldn't have no jokes
that's my point
no joke seems like a bad strategy as a
comedian yet it's one that all feminist
comedians seem to go with
so let's try a different clip we're
gonna we're gonna give up on that one
there's no no laughs to be found there
well nothing makes an event more
exciting than putting some money on it
and with
my bookie it's easier than ever to get
in on the action sometimes you have a
gut feeling about a match up and
sometimes you're just betting on your
team because
they're on your team that's sort of my
strategy but regardless
whether you've been betting for years or
you're ready to play for the first time
my bookie is your go-to this season with
the biggest online selection of bets and
props
they made it simple to win easy to draw
your cash head over to mybookie to
create an account
just use the promo code walsh to claim
your 100 deposit match
all the way up to a thousand dollars
that means if you put 100
in they'll give you another 100 bucks
it's an easy way to jump start your
bankroll
nfl nba mlb everything else they've got
it all on tap and it's
never too late to get started on your
winning season only at
my booking this is from an earlier
netflix
special called uh the special was called
uganda be kidding me
so we're off to a rocky start here when
it comes to finding a funny joke but
let's not judge a book by its cover or
its title
and uh listen to this okay guys give the
worst advice same people were like oh
have you bleached your [ __ ] i'm like
what color is it
i mean no there were options is it my
color i thought it was white is it not
have you seen
what are you [ __ ] stupid you're like
does this person know my ass
has he seen my [ __ ] i'm like what do
you mean he's like oh there are various
colors i mean there it goes there's a
huge spectrum it goes from
white to yellow to lavender to
navy blue someone is a navy blue [ __ ]
who has a navy blue [ __ ] i mean what
are you talking about there's a spectrum
how would i even find out about my own
[ __ ] color how [ __ ] hard it is to
find out your own [ __ ] color
if you're not a gay man first of all my
asshole's a no-fly zone
so if anybody sees it it's going to be
[ __ ] dark out so who cares what
[ __ ] color it is
that will be an accident like oh
whoopsie oopsie-doopsy
okay so this is uh first of all can i
say to begin with
ew uh gross i am
thoroughly repulsed right now i feel
intense nausea
that's a new one for trying to laugh you
know i'm used to feeling depressed
annoyed miserable
while watching these but this is the
first time that i've experienced the
profound desire to go back in time
and gouge out my own eardrums to stop
myself from having to listen to that
but mainly this is just sad here's a
here's like a 52 year old woman
on stage shouting about her [ __ ]
you know things have gone poorly in your
life when that's what you've been
reduced to
i doubt that i could be wrong but i i
doubt that chelsea handler as a young
woman
dreamed of the day when she could stand
on stage and talk about her [ __ ]
in front of a crowd uh but here she is
and it's depressing to watch
taking aside the physical revulsion the
the main feeling you get
when you when you watch chelsea handler
it's sort of like the feeling you get
when maybe you've experienced this when
you see like a middle-aged man
by himself waiting in line on opening
night for a marvel movie
on a friday night it's very tough to see
tough to be around
uh and that's how i feel watching this
but we'll charge through let's go um
let's try to find something that isn't
quite as
anatomical and uh this is chelsea
handler the clip says
babies this is chelsea handler's take on
babies let's see what she has to say
about that
i don't think it's okay for anybody to
have a baby
britney spears i don't think it's okay
to have two babies and then run around
town showing off your hot pocket to
everybody
i think having a baby is a huge
responsibility okay
it's like a five year commitment and you
need to be ready for it
i don't like people who act like they
have a baby and they act like they did
something the rest of us can't figure
out like you took a special test or
somebody
you can't you anybody can have one if
you can't have one you go buy one from
another country you know
it's like oh i'm a mother now chelsea i
can't i'm a mother
i could have been a mother too okay
three times
but i made the right decisions and there
it is there she blows
we get the obligatory abortion joke
emphasis on the scare quotes yeah i
thought it couldn't get more depressing
and pitiful than her screaming about her
[ __ ] for 20 minutes but
now we have her bragging about killing
her baby see this is what you always get
from feminist comedians first of all for
the most part they're terrible people so
that's that's that's the first problem
second
they think that being edgy means simply
saying
inappropriate things forget about
punchline just say something
inappropriate
and of course you mix in every time she
uses the f-bomb you could tell she's
very impressed with herself
that's not edgy it's certainly not
interesting or funny this
this is the edginess of a 14 year old
boy
who scribbles the word sex or something
on the bathroom stall
and in fact chelsea handler has it would
seem i'm guessing been inside many
um men's bathroom stalls and that's
clearly where she gets her inspiration
now i haven't laughed so far to say the
least
i actually am concerned i may never
laugh again after watching this
but i know that the the criticism i'll
get and i get
i got with the uh with the other two
videos is that i cherry-picked the bad
material
you know i was biased in the clips that
i chose which fair enough
it's possible that there are hours and
hours of hilarious
chelsea handler material out there which
i discarded in favor of her rambling
about [ __ ] and abortion
i mean it's possible right uh maybe so
let's watch this is what we'll conclude
with
we'll watch the promo for handler's
latest stand-up special
on uh on i think on uh on hbo and
now here the the people marketing the
special have chosen the best material
this is dressed up
to make her look as good as possible and
to make her her
material look as funny as possible so
we'll conclude with this this is our
best chance for a chuckle and i'm not
looking for a laugh anymore i'm looking
for a chuckle i've downgraded to a
chuckle i'll take even like a
uh that that's what i'm going for now if
we can get one of those
then we're golden and so let's uh let's
watch
let's watch this stop thinking about
what you expect out of life
and start thinking about what life
expects out of you
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a really tricky time right now i
figured it was time to go to a real
therapist
he said i think you lack empathy like a
republican
the thing is i like older men which
brings me to the strong
and deep sexual feelings that i have
developed for andrew cuomo
i wanted to flatten my curve and then i
want to flatten his curve
and then i want us to apex together
spirituality's fine with me as a
component of your lifestyle
i feel spiritual when i'm on mushrooms
i've done
every drug unless there's a new drug
that came out this morning
i've tried it i took my sats tripping on
acid
i didn't get into college but i had a
great time taking that test
i'm growing they're called baby steps
[Music]
chelsea handler evolution is the name of
that special so this is her evolved
this is the culmination of her her whole
career
is that you see i didn't cherry pick the
bad ones if anything i played the good
ones
it's only downhill from there this is so
aggressively
unfun it's almost impressive how could
someone be
a professional comedian for decades
and never managed to say anything funny
ever
it goes back to what i said especially
when you watch that clip about handler
being the weird aunt sort of figure
because here she is bragging about doing
drugs
trying to impress your cousins uh and uh
you know it's
it's it's maybe enough to make you laugh
at her
but this for me because of my incredible
empathy
i just feel bad for this miserable
bitter lonely woman who is falling apart
on stage
and telling us about the color of her
anus i do not laugh at that
the mission fails again but we will
carry on
and try again next time